picking up where i sort of left off in
the last segment i mentioned that joe
joe biden has been very boring for
right-wing media he just sort of is
trying to do the things he promised he's
not succeeding on all of them he's
succeeding on some he's failing on
others
he's mostly liked by americans he
successfully did covet stimulus he's the
most popular
president based on initial approval
rating of the last
nearly 30 years and things are just sort
of like going okay there's no
major scandal uh he even said you know
the
one of the new narratives has been why
isn't joe biden saying something
definitive about the allegations against
andrew cuomo he said last night in his
interview with george stephanopoulos if
the allegations against cuomo are true
then he should resign
up so the right really has no idea what
to do so they're fabricating scandals
one such scandal has been the crisis at
the border
which we discussed earlier and we're
going to keep talking about
but before we get to that they are also
going and going and going on so-called
cancel culture now we've been covering
like once or twice a week just kind of a
tracker
of how fox news has now done three
i don't know if we're on week three or
even into week four
on dr seuss which has been a big topic
of obsession for fox news
and it's become daily programming on a
variety of right-wing network
right-wing networks including fox news
check out some of these delusional
clips here is someone named jillian
turner
who's a fox news correspondent trying to
make some kind of
impassioned speech about this
up ahead plus cancel culture is
spreading like wildfire there is now a
call for generation
x that is x to lead the charge to save
america
from the social media mob can they do it
cancel culture spreading like wildfire
what is she talking about
and on screen during that clip was an
image
of if you saw it mr potato head
dr seuss speedy gonzalez
pepe le pew kermit the frog and miss
piggy characters clearly of
foremost importance to the fox news
audience as you can imagine
there's also as i've said before
something really funny
about the fox news audience supposedly
being all worked up about
literature when a lot of these people
haven't read a book in their lives or
since they were last forced to maybe
when they were little kids
there is some irony there for sure
here's another one
big dramatic teleprompter read about
cancel culture
this one during this one on screen you
will see mr potato head
again speedy gonzales and pepe le pew
and a few dr
seuss book covers latest apparent victim
of the cancel culture that saw dr
seuss's books pulled from the shelves mr
potato head losing his gender
and social media critics saying some
looney tune characters are no longer
welcome
this is what it really looks like to
have nothing to talk about now
i don't even know so we've talked about
the potato head thing
we've talked about dr seuss i have no
idea
about the controversy involving speedy
gonzalez and pepe le pew
my guess is that there
are some people who believe that speedy
gonzales uh plays on tropes about
hispanics and that pepe le pew plays on
tropes about
french people and and smelling i don't
know like i'm
i'm guessing that somewhere someone said
something like that and now fox news
says that it's a cancel culture element
and what's really nuts is that there may
even have been
more total coverage of this
than of the january 6th riots as they
actually happened by trump supporters
like
certainly fox news has covered the riots
but
in a way that doesn't really tell the
story as it is which is
a bunch of trumpists inspired by trump
uh
trespassed and uh committed acts of
violence and
and uh vandalism um then more culture
war stuff
fox news running stories for 36 hours
about the grammys
including one story with the headline
grammy ratings take
massive hit this is something they've
been doing for years when the oscars
come around they say
record low ratings for the oscars and as
i've said before
that kind of makes sense to me um
television audiences are more fractured
than ever and the importance of these
sort of live events and one-time events
the more alternatives there are
the more diminished the importance of
any one event is i haven't watched the
oscars or the grammys in a decade i
don't care about it
but again fox news's motivation is
always to sort of gin up these culture
war elements and then of course any time
that there is either an election coming
up we saw this leading up to 2018
we saw it again leading up to 2020 if
there's an election coming up
or there's a democratic president in the
white house
you can count on right-wing media
talking about
immigrant caravans coming to the border
that democrats don't care about fox
also running a headline about this
yesterday saying
signs of new caravans
heading to the border
they apparently realized that they
can't really get away with caravans
at the southern border so they're going
with the softer headline
there are signs of caravans
heading to the southern border
so like you know maybe in southern
mexico they're noticing some people who
are
packing up food or something like that
then lastly
every single day every single day and we
talked about this earlier so i won't
dwell on it but it's part of the bigger
story
they've been talking about how joe biden
hasn't done a press conference yesterday
it was
55 days without a press conference the
day before it was
54. for weeks it's been where are the
press conferences
and now that joe biden announced the
press conference
for next thursday they went on yesterday
about
it's suspicious that he's announcing it
so far ahead of time so we won't rehash
that
so there's two sides to this on the one
hand
this stuff really doesn't seem to be
affecting joe biden's approval
it's in the very high like 59 to 63 it's
been in that range and it's remaining in
that range
and i know it does you know to a lot of
people that won't sound very high
if you understand the range of
presidential approval if you understand
hyper partisanship if you recall that
donald trump not even for one day
reached 50 approval it it actually is
quite notable
so the the fake scandals don't seem to
be hurting biden
on the other hand what happens when
there is something closer to an
actual biden scandal and there there
well may may be one at some point
you know so far there hasn't been but
there could be
will they have cried wolf so much that
the real biden scandal won't be taken
any more seriously
than you know dr seuss or whatever the
case may be i don't know the answer
but we're going to continue following it
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook called takeover how
a conservative student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audio book from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent role in trump's impeachment
number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
are current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just 4.99 and you can get it
at davidpakman.com takeover
or wherever you buy audiobooks